[Musique]
une perf à la normale se trouve en
liberté seraient donc dans l'illégalité
les personnes anormales sont dangereuses
et laissé en liberté est impossible
[Musique]
clouer quelqu'un aurait pu devoir tu
connais la punition situe entre les
règles j'ai ouvert la porte
on aurait pu se faire tuer
on doit rester caché jusqu'à quand
bonjour plus là puis sortie ce nom tu
dois jamais menti quand tu mens pages
toujours mon papa aussi symbole eh tu as
déjà eu les yeux qui saignent
les soutiens arrivent à faire des choses
que les autres ne peuvent pas faire du
débat spécial
leur pouvoir s'intensifie génération
après génération fumeurs enfants sont
définies comme étant lourdes et armes de
destruction massive
[Musique]
on n'arrivera jamais à sortir d'ici
pinault
cacher ça ne sert à rien
je fais sortir avec la fille
je suis prêt
le cacher
je suis vraiment désolé c'est vrai que
des spéciales
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'adore ma vie je t'aime tellement gary
oublierai jamais jour on s'est
rencontrés petit escargot comment tu
t'appelles cas rien qui nous reçoit
copains - si tu rentres et garonnais
darier la rooney car il avait garé non
car ici plus cargo n'a pu en 2020 l'
aventure commence les hommes y laisse
pas les amis faire des 100 questions je
roule tout seul dans un nouveau monde la
cité perdue d'atlantic city
on va pas perdre notre concentration
patrick c'est pas notre genre de perdre
avec un héros dc patrick sur lequel on
peut miser met tout sur le jeune patrick
sepa nc-17 s'écrit avec un atout
suffisant
bob l'eponge le film et projets en eaux
troubles
ça va être super aventure entre copains
pour la vente hier patrick hyper passé
au co ça tombe bien je suis très douée
pour repasser
[Musique]
c'est parti pour votre rush d'adrénaline
matinale grâce à nous l'émission est
numéro 1
tu vois où je me connais je vois
tu as pourri gâté ses enfants excuse moi
de faire de mon mieux alors que je les
élève seule
vous ne vous rendez pas compte de la
chance que vous avez ici si j'étais le
père noël survolerait cette maison san
marino peu trop tout pour les leçons de
morale nous vous remercions de tout ce
que vous avez fait ici à wm et le mais
nous avons décidé de suivre une autre
direction
alors comme ça tu nous fout d'eux
c'est très dur pour tout le monde sauf
pour moi je gagne lourd mais genre
vraiment ce que je vais dire aux gamins
mois noël approche et je me fais dire et
on a traversé des épreuves fillon va
traverser celle là depuis la mort de
leur mère
je pensais je vous dis papa fort
j'étais persuadé de de les avoir mis à
l'abri de tout ça aurait dû montrer que
tu es t au-dessus de ça et si je te
disais crush b qu elle est à vendre
c'est dans cette radio a connu ses
premiers succès font de vrais l'acheter
avec quoi mon charme et dévastateur
je veux que vous essayez de voir les
choses on est un peu plus grand c'est
une chance en or de nous en sortir alors
retourner dans notre ancienne miss mois
oui et nous on est sans que ça va faire
beaucoup trop de monde à elle est toute
petite
faut se rendre à l'évidence on est dans
la mouise toi t'es gentil tu files et à
pizza je me souviendrai toujours à vos
besoins vous êtes prêts pour le coche
sur wb cul ça c'est mon dans sa victoire
[Musique]
l'important c'est parce que tu le sais
ce que tu as déjà autour de tout
c'est que tu fais tout pour y arriver au
monde tu es mon coeur va exposer
tellement je t'aime
[Musique]
est ce que ton paternel et ouais ils
vont être nombreux à grimper aux rideaux
notre monde s'assombrit un peu plus
chaque jour une nouvelle organisation se
développe au moyen orient et menace la
paix internationale soit tu es avec moi
soit huîtres
un petit cercle nation je suis partant
s'est réuni pour former le conseil de
sécurité du monde
vos pays respectifs estime que vous êtes
les meilleurs tous les civils
vous êtes tous marre
amateur de match segan crescenta et on
les éliminera jusqu'au dernier pour le
retrouver
crois moi
ne doute pas de ma détermination
nous allons remporter cette guerre
c'est une banque salmon commandera
personne ne supplie vrac
[Musique]
ils n'abandonneront jamais c'est ce
qu'on verra un moustique squeeze test
la placer plusieurs tristes heures jean
comme père bobby baldwin khouildi
[Musique]
par mégarde bec
on
mais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça
des soldats
stop
italie
ah la la
[Musique]
5 ordi je suis fan des tangos
architectes j'ai tous vos disques je
pensais pas qu'on allait me reconnaître
ici à paris pourquoi tu es revenu
je vais rencontrer mon petit fils t'as
pas peur qu'elle t'empêche de voir le
petit excusez moi j'aimerais vous parler
ça veut pas attendre je suis important
après tout me reconnaissez pas le tas
jamais il fait juste plus perdre de
temps tu as pensé à ce que tu allé lui
dire je suis votre belle mère
je suis là pour la petite annonce jean
n'avait pas bien lieu elle annonce tombe
réallouer crc jeune étudiante et
discrète
moi seul cortis femme de ménage mais il
faut que t'arrêtes ce cirque
merci on préfère éviter le sucre elle
est d'un banal mais qu'est ce que c'est
que ça j'avais vu une somme aussi froide
sur s'approche d'elle on s'enrhume enfin
venue mais qu'est ce qui te fait il file
dans ta chambre
voilà pour vous aussi pour moi le sou
place je sais que c'est un grand
musicien papa
oui mais moi j'ai été grandement
la raquette saroumane luis pedro alonso
qui trace la route christophe parce que
tu es toujours rien pourquoi il est bien
comme ça je suis ravi d'apprendre que tu
vis des moments privilégiés avec ton
petit fils qui croient que tu es la
femme de ménage de sa mère
tu as vraiment le chic pour toujours te
mettre dans ce genre de situation j'ai
inventé le chic
passez-vous ça se voit
bien posé avec deux oui j'arrive
[Musique]
je suis désolé
je sais pas quoi dire ben moi non que je
sais plus quoi me dire dont mariage à
toi moi j'y suis même pas arriver au
maxi
taxi taxi
[Musique]
desmarais et roy note slip comme l'ipad
iphone baptisée
com
d'inspectorate m sow
justin servent à cacher
[Musique]
où
mais binoche décision
[Musique]
tarascon loi
m
alinghi
[Musique]
'nos m'ont fait une jolie nos bronze
d'art
en haïti
[Musique]